[موسيقى]
في هذا المنزل الذي يبعد 60 كيلومترا عن
العاصمه البولنديه وارسو تعيش اللاجئات
الاوكرانيه ايلينا معها ابنتها بولينا
وكثير من الصغار لست امهات تركن ازواجهن
خلفهن في ميادين القتال خمسه وعشرون فردا
يتقاسمون المساحه نفسها تتناوب الامهات
على رعايه الاطفال ريثما تعود اخريات من
اعمالهن خارج المنزل
افتقد والدي كثيرا لم استطع اقناعهم
بالمجيء الى بولندا لذلك احاول الاتصال
بهم كل يوم وهم بحاجه الى الماء والكهرباء
والتدفئه تعمل الينا خلال ساعات النهار في
منظمه تدعم غيرها من اللاجئين الاوكرانيين
ازمه لجوئهم هي الاسوا في اوروبا منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه هذه الخيمه هي
المحطه الاولى التي يسجل فيها الاوكرانيون
اسمائهم لطلب اللجوء في العاصمه البولنديه
هناك تعاون بين الدول لاعاده توطين
اللاجئين الاوكرانيين هذا امر تقوم به
المنظمات غير الحكوميه فقط انصح اللاجئين
بالذهاب الى دول اوروبا الغربيه لان الدعم
من الحكومه البولنديه شبه معدوم
هذا مركز بتاك خارج وارسو وهو اكبر مركز
للاجئين الاوكرانيين في اوروبا يمكنه
ايواء نحو 20 الف لاجئ في وقت واحد على
وجوههم حيره المصير المجهول بعضهم تفرحهم
بساطه لم الشمل واخرون يحاولون الهرب من
الواقع
لكن اولويه القائمين على المركز هي
التخفيف من صدمات الصغار وتوترهم ينسى
الاطفال قليلا اما الم الكبار فيستمر
الوضع صعب هنا لا يوجد ما يكفي من الطعام
هؤلاء المتطوعون يتجولون فقط لماذا ياتون
هنا هم لا يتحدثون لغتنا ولا
يفهمتنا لا خصوصيه هنا وربما لا راح لكنها
مساحه امنه ودافئه تقيهم خطر الموت بنار
الحرب وتحميهم من برد الشتاء القارص جاؤوا
هنا بنيه الاقامه المؤقته لكن كثيرين منهم
لم يغادروا المكان منذ نحو عام هم محظوظون
رغم ذلك بالمقارنه مع غيرهم ممن ظلوا
عالقين في اوكرانيا او جاءوا لاجئين من
بلاد اخرى لكن اللاجئين الاوكرانيين
كغيرهم من اللاجئين يتحولوا مؤقتهم
تدريجيا الى دائم ويفكرون في جدول الرجوع
لا لا ارغب في العوده اريد البقاء في
بولندا ادركت ان مستقبل اطفالي هنا وليس
في اوكرانيا كما انه لم يعد هناك احد
ليفيزا بروجيا كي اعود اليه والحرب طالت
كثيرا
ازمه ستستمر وتتفاقم ما دامت بندقيات
المقاتلين مصوبه نحو الصدور محمد المدهون
الجزيره